welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and season 2 of Marvel
Studios what if comes out this week the
show continues its Anthology nature
while making some connections to season
one plot lines and the broader MCU we're
going Episode by episode to talk about
what we might expect and even give an
early review for the season ooh this is
the sneak peek where we take the
temperature of whatever we're watching
while we head into the next episode or
look ahead into the next week of nerdom
joining me on this episode the Santa
Claus of new rock stars if you want to
call them that it's John Costa wrote
that mean you know D why would that be
mean incredibly Jolly you're antiw anti-
Jolly I wrote that I wrote it it was me
I was mean to myself well I quickly want
to hear your thoughts on the two
episodes we got to see episode one and
three that's right uh you and me you go
first I I was I why did they jump which
we could probably get into later into
the actual discussion let talk about it
we saw episod one we saw episode one we
saw episode three that was uh what if no
uh what if nebula joined the Nova cor
and what if Christmas episode happy
Saved Christmas we didn't get to see um
the what if Peter quills
mightiest attacked Earth Earth's
Mightiest Heroes um so we're going to
talk about those first two episodes what
we saw what we liked what we didn't like
and then we'll talk broadly about what
we kind of expect about the other seven
episodes that are coming this season
Jesus um the first one we saw was what
if uh nebula joined the Nova Corp um
there will be some light spoilers in our
discussion but we'll keep it pretty
clean just kind of like um you know what
the episode was maybe inspired by some
of the themes the tone those kinds of
things we won't get into like cameos and
plots and things like that unless they
already exist in trailer footage does
that sound good okay okay um what if
nebula joined the novacore I thought it
was really interesting it takes place
theoretically before the events of the
first Guardians of the Galaxy movie I
think we saw trailer footage that Ronin
is going to be in the episode so he's
kind of one of the people yeah in there
so it takes place before Guardians
volume one um I thought this was a
really kind of good tone Setter for this
season it's very like Chinatown Blade
Runner like newr City uh episode when
you said Chinatown were you thinking big
trouble little China no I was thinking
of Chinatown
oh Kurt Russell is in big trouble little
is that Kurt Russell that's K Russell
big trouble little CH what do you mean
you think it's okay it is um o 80s icon
making his debut again um is Kurt
Russell in that episode no no no but we
know that he's going to be in Earth's
Mightiest Heroes and it's 80s Kurt
Russell so he's just coming back as big
trouble of China the episode was great I
my question for you because you did even
mention that it takes place before the
Guardians first movie in the trailer we
do see yando's like body on the ground
we see a lion on the ground and what is
and we see
nebula yeah Dawn the new mohawk yep so
what is what was yandu doing in the
first movie cuz remember he did
interfere with the Nova core in the
first movie so yeah at that time he's a
ravager we know that like gosh it's been
a while since I've seen Guardians volume
one for whatever reason such a good
movie um Peter and yandu at that point
in the movie don't have the best
relationship right Peter's off doing his
own thing he's finding the power stone
or whatever it is um yeah I we don't
really know what the story is we know
he's on xand are we don't it doesn't
seem like from the trailer footage that
he's part of the Nova cor um so it's
hard to tell he's in an alley feels a
little shady maybe he's doing kind of
like some underground stuff it feels
like he must be important because if we
do have nebula in the novacore coming up
to his dead body and then the next cut
is her with the novacore suit on and
still Dawning his like little Mohawk fan
I'm like oh this must be something
important to her well and you know we
don't I'll say this this is is a little
bit of a review again we're trying to
keep it more spoiler-free than not um
but you know we watched this episode so
we have a lot of the facts um seems like
seems like nebula and yandu had some
past some history some relationship that
we're not totally clear on um so it's
hard to tell maybe he was her informant
or something like that that's the tone
of this episode is very like you know
who's informing on who and we got to get
to the bottom of this thing and that's
why I'm sort of relating it to Chinatown
CU it kind of feels like a cross City
Adventure trying to like get information
out of different people this season of
what if seems like it's going to be
really genre heavy right it feels like a
lot of the episodes at least from the
ones that we saw are like Hey we're
doing Blade Runner or hey we're doing
Die Hard or or whatever it is is that
something that like we didn't get a ton
of in season one it feels like almost
like a season of Community or something
like that is that is that fun for you I
think it's fun do you think it's a
spoiler say saying that it's going to be
like Blade Runner and it's going to be
like die hard I think you can tell from
the trailer well we know we've seen
happy Hogan in the vents you know you
could kind of get the Blade Runner stuff
from from looking at the trailers yeah
that's true um I it's so funny I would
have never guessed Blade Runner um and
to be fair Blade Runner is a good movie
but go back and watch it and then be
like wow what's weird with this scene
there was one scene in Blade Runner when
I rewatched it recently where I was like
oh Indiana Jones don't do that
cuz it's it's it's his name it's what's
his name Harrison Ford it's Harrison
Ford you guys I forgot Harrison Ford's
name God he's going to come down and
kill me um he's going to crash his
airplane stop I was I was going to make
the joke and then I didn't want to make
the joke I didn't want to make the Sully
joke um
but it's so [__] up it's so [__] up
but no um I I I like where they're going
I like that idea I think it's also
easier and people love Nostalgia so
people are going to watch it and be like
oh I remember this and what US nerds do
best to be like um well I think it's fun
this show has an opportunity to do stuff
that other things in the MCU didn't get
to do part of this episode we also want
to kind of share with you some of the
things we intended a Q&A afterward and
got to hear from some of the creators
and you know some of the things that
people in Marvel animation keep talking
about is a little bit of Freedom when it
comes to making these shows because they
don't feel so beholden to you know MCU
house style or having to interconnect
with a bunch of different movies and and
and TV shows so I think it's going to be
a nice little break from some of the
kind of like Marvel house style stuff
which is still fun and they can still go
you know the difference between a movie
like Captain America and the Winter
Soldier and a movie like you know the
Marvels is pretty vast um so there is a
lot of room to play there but they even
have more opportunities here you said
this was your favorite of the two that
we saw is that right this is my favorite
of the two um I'm also biased because
it's nebula and they even knew that
nebula was was a fan favorite the last
season and people wanted more so they're
making this episode around them and I
was like yes this is great I like how uh
dirty it is how gritty it is exactly the
same reviews they're giving for Ekko um
I think it's more fun but I'm also not
the
biggest I I like Christmas episodes yeah
who doesn't but I also was
like P added to the pile and it is it is
like a Christmas episode for
Christmas merch
it is like it is a Christmas episode
it's like oh you want to see Captain
America Steve Rogers as an elf who
doesn't like it's it's perfect but it's
also like yeah I'm going to get this as
like a shirt or socks and then I'm going
to put it on the pile of things we going
to watch every December it's in the
trailer there is a shot of Tony Stark
like holding up Iron Man socks or
whatever it it's just Hammer with Iron
Man socks it does feel like that's
there's going to be like a link to a
shop when I like it but I I did like
this episode more and it also uh has
like characters that we uh I I wasn't
expecting to see in the first episode
absolutely Justin Hammer being one of
them you know we saw these episodes
before the new trailer came out uh with
with Justin hammer in it and the
audience was like pretty surprised that
that uh Sam Rockwell came back um this
is a light spoiler he dances that's a
spoiler good that's a spoiler it's good
um so all the Justin Hammer stuff he
comes back he's a lot of fun I think my
favorite parts from this episode episode
are you're right like the plot of it is
fun but it is similar to some other
things that we've seen the like oneoff
jokes about like what the Avengers might
be up to around Christmas time is what
like really tickled me and I I had a lot
of fun I think that's fun yeah yeah it's
just a Christmas episode I'm going to be
excited when it comes out but I'm also
like that's that's that's my review put
in Grinch over here my letter box for
that
episode's okay I'm not a grinch because
of it I'm just like re well it I I took
it and it hurt my
feelings my cold dead heart um no it's
very fun and it and those CPS are very
fun after watching that trailer that
released after we all got to go watch
those episodes I was like I'm much more
excited for the other Eight Episodes uh
and than this one yeah and that's maybe
what swayed me because if I came out of
there right now and then did this I'd be
like it's so fun it's so cool gave me a
little couple days to digest it we were
trying to kind of figure out and we're
going to get to a little bit of um how
the sausage gets made here at the end of
the episode if that's something you're
curious about um but we were kind of
talking in the office why do they choose
to show us these episodes it's an
anthology theoretically they could show
us any number of different episodes I
know at ComicCon last year they showed
the Hydra stomper Peggy Carter episode
um so I think it's probably just because
they they wanted to show us the first
episode that's the nebula one and the
Christmas episode is like a totally
different episode from the first one the
first one's really serious and hardcore
this one's like a little bit more light
and fun and christmy and maybe they
wanted to get us kind of like in the
Christmas spirit or something absolutely
I also think the last thing I'd want to
do is Show the cohor episode um to a
pack of spoilers to AA wol no well no
because of the spoilers we would
immediately go online like and it's not
us but there are people out there who
was that I'm not going to get into it
there was someone that posted like a
giant spoiler ones for eternals and I
wanted to go fight them immediately I
think it was variety wasn't it variety
just put it as the headline cover oh my
God and so doing that with korti is like
this is original character please don't
spoil it they probably definitely don't
want to do Doctor Strange intervene why
would you ever make that in one of our
first two you probably don't want to do
the 16021 it's little bit more unique
that's why and even Earth's Mightiest
Heroes cuz we were bringing in the 80s
Avengers so it's like yeah you can't
spoil a lot of these episodes but
Christmas uh Happy saving Christmas
isn't really a big spoiler episode and
nebula's episode entering the season is
just really tonally cool to look into
let's talk about this Peter Quill
Earth's Mightiest Heroes episode this is
probably the episode that I'm most
excited about apart from the episodes
that are like further from normal right
the 1602 episode I'm very excited for
the strange Supreme episode I'm really
excited for the cordi episode I'm really
excited for the rest of them I know that
that's a big a long there the grand you
missed the Grand Master one yeah yeah
I'm excited for that one but like of the
like normal episodes of what if that
we're going to get I think I'm most
excited about this Peter Quill how are
you defining what's normal I guess are
you just saying because it's like normal
people I don't know I they're all so
weird I know I know I think like this
one feels more similar to some of the
episodes we were getting in season one
similarly like the Grand Master episode
was originally a part of season 1 Hydra
stomper is a character that we got in
season that's true this this is one
where it's like oh it's just what if we
turned it a little bit halfway there's
ones where they're literally what if
strange intervene we're turning the full
flipping it over flip it over I'm also
very excited for the hell episode we'll
get that in a second yeah um I'm curious
you so you just did the breakdown of
this trailer you sort of had like this
Theory or maybe you found evidence of it
that like Peter Quill was going to be
helping ego okay do some of the seating
talk to me about it okay talk to me
about it y talk to me about it what I'm
I okay good so why I think he's
assisting him is I don't know it just
feels like the logic of that we're
seeing the ego rocks and it's 80s ego
rocks so if he is continually planting
it like he was in the first movie you're
referring to like the like weird Dusty
looking those creatures that well the
ego yeah the people in the desert the
people in the desert The Rock people it
was it was a bunch of people from
burning man they got covered
in they pomp they pompe stayed out there
and now they're now they're sentient
again holy [__] what if you can take it
but just put me and John over there two
JC's set us up some residuals give me
some those residuals no but it's like if
he's still going with that plan and it's
going as according to plan I was like
okay none of these if it was Peter Quill
they he could make the rocks look like
him I don't think he's making the rocks
look like his dad uh so I was like I
think he's just assisting him in still
furthering that plan of planting himself
on every planet and then destroying it
but he has to bring up that terrain to
go against the Avengers because they're
here to actually fight I think that is
personally a different planet I don't
think they're on Earth uh I think
they're like fighting quill and then
they figure out that oh they need to go
to Ego and they're going to do you think
we'll see ego in the like living planet
form in this episode be a lot of I
believe that that's what I think I and I
talk about this we're not going to get
too hard into this I talk about this in
the trailer breakdown with hela's
episode it says what if she found the
ten Rings right it's not she discovered
them so she could have easily just ran
into someone with them she didn't find
them someone else is using them she's
just like oh I could use this to my
advantage um and that's how I kind of
feel with this episode we're focusing
really hard that it's quill and there's
a bigger man above him and that's ego
that's actually doing a lot of those
yeah we definitely see when Woo is going
to be in that hel episode presumably
he's still the person who discovers the
10 rings and hel just is like hey those
look cool yeah cool I have those can we
be on a team together um yeah I'm I'm
really excited for this one mostly cuz
I'm curious to see what a ego Peter
relationship looks like when working as
a team we got a brief look at that in
Guardians Volume 2 but then it quickly
shattered and ego became a piece of [__]
and and then the Black Panther episode
of what if it just was him mopping like
a Dairy Queen and then turning around to
his dad right right who teenage him
which I thought immediately too and I
was like oh maybe this is and I was like
wait he's a kid he's an adult in that
he's a child now yeah I I'm more excited
for this episode just for the80s
Avengers and I think they know that it's
a great list do we want to run through
them real fast yes please go yes I don't
have a memory oh it's tachaka it's t
it's Bucky it's U marll we have uh King
tachaka we have Hank Pimp's Ant-Man and
then I saw a little piece that's wa
that's wasp the mom oh maybe we had a
little Michelle saw I saw I saw the
little wings and her when they came down
on the at the carnival I probably should
know I I've been really wanting an
Ant-Man and the WASP throwback to Hank
and Janet for a long time I think
everyone does we get that little tiny
taste of it in the first Ant-Man movie
or maybe is it in the second Ant-Man
movie I think it's second cuz we see a
little flash where you she disappear
into the quantum realm um love to see
more of that and then we have Thor all
the Ageless ones made it the
still um but also uh yeah I think and
it's interesting because I'm very
excited to see quill like as a child
with the Star-Lord powers and owning
them but I'm more excited to see this
lineup fight together and one of the
things I really like about the promo
material we've seen for this episode is
they are repeating some of the shots
that we've gotten iconically through the
MCU the first the teamup shot from the
first Avengers movie that cool slow-mo
shot where they're all kind of like in
slow motion moving where my break down
where we on my breakdown uh that shot
too and it it's like almost as if th
those moments are like Canon moments in
the MCU and of course like they're just
kind of like doing little winks and nods
to past MCU films but I do think it's
fun that like every single Avengers team
in all the multiverses has like this
exct act same kind of like yeah I love
it I'm I'm very excited for this episode
thanks for reminding me about it because
fun I just I you I just want I don't
know why I'm obsessed with the idea of
like Hank pims Ant-Man and tachaka
working together maybe because we never
would see that and I'm like yeah let me
see these two people that one's very
Dead uh and then one is not doing
Ant-Man things anymore and we should say
you know Michael Douglas came in and did
such a great job with uh what if season
1 he was was so good in that episode he
ended up being one of the my favorite
villains from That season um and the
creators of the show sort of said like
we called Michael up and he was like so
game to do this episode and he gave it
his all so I think like that's going to
be one of the performances to look out
for for this season we're going to talk
about the next six episodes and what to
expect um from those but first this
video is sponsored by Helix sleep and
good because I sleep better on my Helix
mattress than I ever used to and now
everybody can get 20% off on a helix
mattress plus two free pillows if you're
feeling overwhelmed at the thought of
finding the perfect mattress I get it
I've been there but helix's sleep quiz
makes it so easy you just take the quiz
and Helix finds the perfect mattress for
you I wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with the dusk Lux Helix
mattress this year Helix launched their
newest and most high-end collection yet
the Helix Elite mattresses the Helix
Elite collection includes six different
mattress models that combine personal
comfort with highend luxury so if you're
ever on the fence about getting a new
mattress it's time to jump off that
fence and land on a helix Elite Helix
delivers your mattress right to your
door with free shipping in the United
States the mattress comes rolled up in a
box and is super easy to set up yourself
Helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
get more than 3 months to make sure that
you love your mattress Helix mattresses
have a 10-year warranty Helix even
offers financing options of flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away I love my Helix
mattress and I think you would too if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix sleep you can click the link below
or go to helixsleep.com rockstars to get
20% off your Helix mattress plus two
free pillows I just want to say hey
check out nerd rot. shop you can grab
the latest and greatest new Rockstar
gear Jessica and I right now are repping
some sort of what if inspired teas we've
got a C sort of like a tour like a tour
t-shirt I don't know if you can see this
but at the very bottom it's got all the
nine Realms this is nine Realms tour
you've got you know Asgard midgard n
valer vanaheim s of f all the things I'm
not Norse um I've got a shirt that's
inspired by the this what if Tony Stark
ran into the grandm episode it's like
our SAR cart shirt we got a bunch of OG
classic Avengers in different vehicles
that like we think that they would drive
Tony's got this cool Formula 1 car uh we
put Spider-man on a
bike um Thor's got a chariot some cool
stuff um uh check out N rot. Shop we
also heard that you really loved our god
of story shirt so we doubled down and we
came out with this sick new for all time
always tea to celebrate the mcu's newest
God of stories um and it's just like
Loki with the ell world's Tree World
tree um and I love it he's there for all
time it's a good shirt it's a great it's
beautiful the art is insane um you I
don't think we're going to do this but
you recommended putting them on cards
and I was like yes this makes this makes
sense for the back of cards we're trying
to figure out how to do playing cards
maybe in maybe next year but support the
channel and and check out our great
merch options over at nerd rot. shop
don't forget to subscribe to all three
channels on the new rockstars Network
the channel we're on right now new
rockstars of course the Deep dive and
the set that we're on right now the
breakroom um and maybe we'll have more
channels in the New Year Jesus Christ
who knows get slow down everybody too
much slow down get on that bike get on
that bike all right there's six more
episodes that we didn't get to see so
let's run through those and give our
thoughts real fast so uh the SEC the
fourth episode coming out this year is
this is coming out on Christmas Day what
if Iron Man crashed into the Grand
Master we've seen not too much from this
episode we've seen them sort of like
racing around in cars don't really know
what's going on we know that um uh Jeff
Goldblum is back one of the compliments
that the writers bragged about during
our Q&A was that Jeff specifically was
like no this like really really really
feels like my character so like thank
you guys guys for for writing to The
Grandmaster I'm just excited to see the
grandmas again I thought that he was so
fun and we didn't get to see him in Thor
love and thunder even though there was
like a deleted scene or something that
didn't get shot that had him in it I
think this is just going to be like a
goofy fun romp around SAR this is the
this feels like the Thor episode of the
party Thor the party God kind of episode
yes where like oh we got a here's all
the craziest things that are going to
happen and then we're back to a little
bit to normal um um there's one scene in
it cuz Gamora is in it right is that is
that so that shot with her I think she
that's what I think that shot is in that
episode and then cuz I but I'm not 100%
sure on it but it does she's in the same
armor she's in the same look so I was
like oh I think you know how before they
started battling in Ragnarok they were
all in that like like Thor was in that
like Prison Room with G and and stuff I
think it's a slightly different world
now where he's just like kidnapping them
and they're in their own cells and
instead it's not like a shared space um
and that's them they're going to each
get like a open the door right they're
coming well so who do you want to see
Gamora if if we are doing sort of
another Gladiator games type of thing
that maybe devolves into some car stuff
who do you want to see Gamora fight the
most I have my pick who was yours I
really really wanted in the car in this
cars episode specifically in this in the
cars episode yeah yeah I I want a what
if episode that is like sad and tragic
and it is like something about Gamora
and nebula when they were kids and
Thanos was making them like fight each
other and so if I can't get that I want
to see nebula and Gamora face off
because we've never really gotten to see
them fight we've gotten to like hear
them talk about how they've had to fight
each other we did see like a little bit
of them fighting in Guardians volume one
the in the sort of third act but like I
want to see the like sister versus
sister like really emot weighty fight
between the two of them but I sorry who
did who do you want to see gamorra fight
I don't want to see Gamora fight anyone
cuz that's all she's been doing yeah
that's um and that's why I also don't
want to see her fighter sister cuz if
she fought her in the first movie fought
her in the second movie and then fought
her at uh endgame yeah I'm like I I
think I've seen her fight enough I like
I think my favorite part of nebula is
her when she is in the final Guardians
movie being like I'm just tired I'm
exhausted please stop this um yeah I
don't really care gamorra fights and
that episode um but I do always want
Gamora winning and it's interesting
because I like Gamora more in what if
than I do in the MCU MC I'm always like
rooting but I think it's because she's
like so independent and what if they
make her and she is independent in the
MCU as Zoe Sana especially in Guardians
3 yes that one and that's what I was
like I I'm so happy James gun was like
no this is a different Gamora you guys
please stop um and that's the Gamora I
like I'm like oh she's independent she's
ruling things she's very strong
man I thought that that Gamora Peter
Quill ending for their relationship was
like so perfect in in like a I don't
want this to happen kind of way but like
I accept that this is what needs to
happen almost like the ending of this is
a weird reference for Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 but like almost like the
ending of la la land where you're like I
kind of want them to get together but
you know it's not really right so you're
happy that it goes the way that it goes
I've never seen L
land what are you doing tonight
um another episode they do
that
um cut that no don't cut it out um all
right episode five of this season is
what if Captain Carter fought the
hydromer this is this was set up in
season one uh we saw Steve as the sort
of like Hydra stomper at one point we
don't know a ton about this Hydra
stomper episode I think this is the one
we've probably seen in trailers the
least the most we've seen of it has sort
of been like um Captain Carter and The
Watcher yeah so I don't know if they're
implying that like Captain Carter is
now like that's a pretty big
conversation to have with a watcher just
like a normal person I I'm more I'm more
which maybe we'll figure out as we keep
going through
this why Peggy Carter I don't know I
don't I I love Peggy Carter I you guys
don't come at me I love Peggy Carter
good for you but I I [__] I loved her
show so that's why I'm like uh I'm I'm
like what does the Watcher Ben diagram
me the Watcher and Peggy Carter and tell
me what is in the center of that in
which they would both meet each other
they just both met at one of those chess
boards at Central Park and they were
like the watch like let me show you the
universe let me show you you beat me in
the game of chess check mate watch this
[__] what is this that's how he she
kills the [__] out of yeah breaks her
neck in Central Park would be the first
person forgot humans were that week I
forgot humans were that weak but no I'm
so I'm so I I'm interested when I say
confused don't take it negatively it's
more so I like I'm very curious to what
that storyline will be yeah yeah okay so
so uh moving on here uh the sixth
episode of the Season what if cohor
reshaped the world we know a little bit
about this uh not too too much and now
correct me I'm I'm wrong Jessica I
believe that this is the first original
character in the MCU that has sort of
been like the titular character of a
thing right like of course there's a lot
of other original characters in the MCU
but but it's pretty rare that like an
entirely original not from the comics
character is like the lead yeah no 100%
yeah this is it's it's again in the most
positive way the wildest thing uh it's
so crazy to me and it is
true it's like I don't think they've
ever I'm trying to think of like I'm I'm
just trying to think off the top of my
Dome about the original characters
Marvel has made and has been like here's
their own episode without us knowing
anything about them I mean genuinely
like the closest we've gotten to
something like that is you know uh a
Captain Britain or or a captain Carter
or like a Miles Morales or an eeko or a
Marvel which is like a person who's
really new to the comics that we've got
a show from but but for the first time
this is like a new character for these
shows and um you did this great work on
the breakdown kind of piecing some
things together that kahori somehow has
the space Stone and Thanos is trying to
get it that's presumably his the last
infinity stone he needs yes it it seems
that this is us piecing together what we
have from the trailer right because also
Peggy Carter is in that scene where
Thanos comes out of like his portal so I
don't know if that's I don't think
that's kori's episode I right Eric
either yeah Eric deduces that it's the
ending episode that involves Hela too um
so they they Cort could show up in more
than one episode and I really hope she
does but similar to last season where
the last two episodes were sort of like
a culmination of the full season yeah
that and I think that's what is going to
happen and that's going to be her
introduction into the group of what if
and because we see in the trailer that
she falls into the water she goes down
and you see the blue light beaming up
that's where she probably gets it comes
up and she's sees the entire tribe she's
glowing with her powers and that's why
there's a scene where she's like we have
these like mythical Buffalo or bison
it's the big ass creatures and I think
it's on a plane that we aren't on she's
like training somewhere else she's
that's right those um bison seem super
other worldly they other worldly and I
think she's training and prepared to
throw ships over to the [__] hell
let's run through these final three
episodes quickly what if Hela found the
10 Rings we know that searer is going to
be in this episode uh wwo is going to be
in it Odin so that's really exciting I'm
I'm just hoping that we see a little sha
a little shuni in that episode I know it
takes place majority in the past but we
do think that there's some modernish New
York stuff happening in that episode so
maybe we'll get there maybe they'll go
to San Francisco who knows we do know
that Shawn and Katie are in New York
because they were just recently with
Wong at the sanctum sorum so maybe
they'll show up uh what if the assembled
in 1602 this one feels like the most
sort of like probably not going to
connect to some of the other episodes
it's based off of this great Neil Gaiman
comic run um of the same name um we also
have a great shirt for that episode it's
like an old school super cool Scarlet
Witch and it's uh 1602 made it into a
hoodie check it out um we should get you
that shirt I have so many I have so much
Scarlet Witch gear and then the last one
is what if strange Supreme intervened so
it it this will this is kind of a really
interesting episode we don't know what
it's going to be about that's the one we
probably have the least plot kind of
idea about even though we obviously got
a lot of strange Supreme in season 1
yeah the uh the only thing I think I can
pull away and everyone should take away
from this episode is strange Supreme is
supposed to be watching killmonger and
Zola in that little Cube so if he's
intervening who's watching those two in
that Cube not let loose kilmonger is
going to be in this season so we don't
know if it's be that episode or a
different episode if it's that specific
killmonger if it's a different
killmonger I I'm I I don't trust Supreme
at all I do not trust him and that
episode was called when the strange
Supreme was watching kilmonger Zola that
episode is called like what if the
Watcher broke his oath and at the end of
that episode he's like what are friends
for and then now we have an episode
called what if Doctor Strange or what if
strange Supreme had to intervene and I'm
like also know there's he's leaving his
post we know there's a line in the
trailer where the Watcher says at some
point like I don't normally do sequels
but I'll make an exception or whatever
that's not in the first episode of the
season so that's a sequel to maybe the
strange Supreme episodes from the first
season so okay uh sorry we had to zip
through those it's time for our heat
check Jess we've seen two episodes we've
seen two
trailers uh where are we with this with
this season of Whata if do you think
it's going to surpass your expectations
and maybe uh you're going to enjoy it
more than season 1 um where where is
this show you think it's going to kind
of land for you in terms of other MCU
shows this is personally for me I think
it's going to exceed my expectations for
season one because they can do whatever
they want and I think they're really
owning that this season even from the
Q&A they're clearly like yeah we don't
we're not in the same world as you guys
like we're same property but we can do
whatever the hell we kind of want so I
think they're going to exceed
expectations push more and these
episodes feel different than first
episode we have an episode for Kor like
the these are different episodes than
what we got in the first season the
first season was like the same
characters we've seen just TW twist it a
little bit very much more excited for
season 2 um is it going to
exceed yeah I think so I think so it's
going to exceed my expectations for the
other Marvel TV shows um if I had to put
it in like a ranking it's hard because
like what if season one feels so
different than this season um but this
season going off the trailer I would put
like out of all the Marvel
shows number four whoa number four I'm
very excited for I'm you guys don't
understand how excited I am for that
strange Supreme episode cohort's episode
and Hell finding the 10 rings that is
insane to me yeah give that woman in the
10 Rings you're out of your mind she's
colonizing she's going crazy it's going
to be a ton of fun Jessica you're going
to be here to break those episodes down
yeah I'll be here to help you as much as
I can hi from behind the scenes um that
is it for this episode of the sneak peek
we will see more of you guys this week
as we break these episodes down can't
wait follow uh new rockstars on Twitter
follow Jessica Lulu Clemens follow me at
cona and hey we'll see you next week bye
thank you so much for
[Music]
[Applause]
watching